ma in realtà mi stavo annoiando
praticamente era tiple 19 18 qualche
giorno prima di natale comunque a
dicembre e stavo controllando i commenti
sotto il video è cancello l'ennesimo
spammer perché per anni ci sono stati
spammer sotto i video di youtube
se no come quelli zio quei parenti che
ogni volta che gli inviti per le feste
dicono soltanto stronzate dalla matiz la
sera però gli inviti comunque perché
ormai sono di famiglia
nell'ultimo periodo tra l'altro che sono
nati di nuove razze virgolette si sono
quelli che fanno lo spam in rima ciao
sono giulio questo è il mio canale e se
non hai niente da fare ti invito a
cliccare i miei video sono divertenti
questo lo sai ma quand'è che a cagare te
ne vai volendo non è che diano
eccessivamente fastidio voglio dire il
problema è che adesso con adesso ormai
nell'ultimo anno con i nuovi commenti di
youtube e quelli più discussi vanno in
alto e puntualmente quelli più discussi
sono quelli in cui sultano lo spammer e
quindi tu sei lì a dire che è arrivato
il momento della giornata scuola scola
cancella scroll ascona cancella e
siccome appunto mi stavo annoiando
mi sono detto ma funzionerà questo tipo
di spam
o comunque in generale lo spam su
youtube aiuta a far crescere il canale e
così ho creato dark angel kraft
[Musica]
dark e inge kraft è un canale che ho
creato il 20 dicembre per provare questa
teoria la teoria dello spam
ma andando più nel generale molta gente
mi scrive come faccio ad iniziare su
youtube come faccio a far vedere i miei
video come si fa senza una spintarella e
io rispondo sempre che non ne ho idea
perchè ora è una giungla per davvero nel
senso che ormai tutti fanno tutto ed è
un casino annaspare fuori dall'acqua e
allora mi sono detto vediamo proviamo ad
aprire un canale da zero senza spinte
senza aiuti senza nulla proprio da zero
con una mail nuova a vedere come si
riesce a sopravvivere tra virgolette in
su youtube
e siccome volevo testare i dati e non
soltanto aprire un canale e basta
ho pensato a quale fosse il modo
migliore per fare visual video comici
parodie recensioni e un po troppo lungo
sono andato subito sul sicuro però che
in play ma quali gameplay minecraft
ovviamente ma proprio il fiore
all'occhiello di youtube italia e come
lo chiamò siccome non posso essere io
non posso essere io toby a fare i video
usiamo lo pseudonimo e fingiamo di
essere molto molto giovani perché nel
panorama di minecraft la media l'età
media ma non lo dico con cattiveria e
proprio dati alla mano l'età media è
sotto i 16 anni diciamo poi c'è chi è
molto più grandi c'è chi è molto più
piccolo ma la media è quella quindi un
po per parodia ma ve ne sono
l'invito dopo ho chiamato il canale xx
dark age il kraft xx quanto può essere
[ __ ] 1
ho cercato in due secondi un avatar è un
banner da usare vi piace il banner l'ho
creato io è bello eh ho caricato il mio
primo video
salve a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti nel
mio canale io sono massimiliano chiamato
su youtube dark angel kraft con la voce
modificata non è che ci sia molto di
contenuto dentro questi video mi sono
solo un po divertito a dire qualche
agatina sui miei figli genitori e
scusate se parlo piano ma in questo
momento mi hanno ammazzato almeno sul
divano cioè di solito metto le faccio
mettere i piedi alla bottiglia del
liquido che beve lei tipo lui si
chiamino cacciani pizzica la lola e
gliela metto via e la lascia dormire in
pace sul divano quindi perdonatemi se
parlo piano e dopo averlo caricato
aspettato qualche ora soldato che
iniziando da zero assoluto dopo qualche
ora le visualizzazioni sono rimaste da
zero e allora sono partito fracassando
mi pozzi con il contro il c contro il v
spammando come un cane sotto tutti mino
soltanto di minecraft però e ci aiutiamo
tra colleghi diciamo scrivendo cose
all'inizio tipo complimenti si è molto
simpatico mi iscrivo ti iscrivi anche tu
proprio la bici dello spam
questo per quasi tre ore o spammato
sotto i canali e le prime due risposte
sono state sotto mio video iscritto
ricambi a cui risposto va bene e poi più
bello del mondo complimenti sei molto
simpatico ma io sono femmine
la prima figura di merda subito e
iniziamo piano piano ad avere le prime
trenta quaranta visual che ripeto per un
canale che ha iniziato da zero senza
partnership senza aiuti di nessun tipo
e abbastanza 40 persone che hanno visto
video video di merda ma sempre un video
hanno visto in contemporanea con il
caricamento del secondo video ho cercato
di cambiare tipo di spam
questi erano tutti testo ovviamente per
vedere quale avrebbe funzionato meglio
sono passato anch'io alle rime e questo
facendolo sotto i video dei canali con
un po più di scritti del bie
ringrazio per i video che hai fatto mi
hai fatto la voglia di iniziare a farli
mi servono un po di iscritti non sono
teo de carli non do fastidio a nessuno
ti giuro visita il mio canale e
divertimento sicuro mettendomi
mi piace il mio stesso delle provavo tub
e poi è uscito il secondo video contest
ovviamente perché anche i video erano
strutturati in modo da essere ogni
singolo video un modo per prendere
iscritti primo video presentazione
ovviamente secondo video contest è di 15
iscritti raggiunti
ovviamente sempre aggiungendoci qualche
cagata di mio perché altrimenti non mi
divertivo a farlo
scusate un attimo
chiedo scusa e rieccomi è la mia
sorellina e poi ho assistito a quello
che molto probabilmente ha fatto
irritare un vulcano in giappone per
l'effetto farfalla sotto mio commento di
spam
dove dicevo iscritto ricambi mi ha
risposto un'altra persona con scritto in
scrittori un commento di spam sotto un
altro commento di spam
dopo questo possono chiudere internet
per mac e siccome il contest è stato per
anni una parte importante
dell'acquisizione di iscritti infatti
anche io ne feci un paio ai tempi avevo
mi sembra tremila iscritti era proprio
agli inizi sono arrivati un sacco di
commenti e diviso al sotto quel video li
quindi quello funziona per davvero e non
solo iscritti e commenti per partecipare
a contest ma anche la mia prima
collaborazione
se per caso hai la 1.8 possiamo
collaborare ero sinceramente contento
perché il secondo video l'ho caricato il
secondo giorno del canale proprio il
giorno dopo sono riuscito ad avere una
collaborazione va bene quando vuoi farla
oggi faccio un video ti do un nome nel
server troviamo una fazione la glissiamo
record a posto su youtube e metto sul
collegamento tuo canale sono così
vecchio da non aver capito metà del
commento e quindi chiedo ma tu hai
minecraft di originale io sì e lui mi ha
scritto premium comprato con i cash
porca [ __ ] arrivato un gangster mi dà
il nome del server vado dentro server e
lo aspetto per quasi due ore ma non
arriva
sarò sincero ci sono rimasto male e dopo
ste due ore ad aspettarlo inutilmente
mi scrive scusa mi ero dimenticato e
questa è stata la mia prima
collaborazione ed era giunto il tempo di
caricare il terzo video il terzo giorno
male vi ringrazio ha partecipato anche
il mio amico interista sbarazzino paolo
che saluto un salutone a d'intervista
sbarazzino ed è quel punto che mi è
sorto dubbio di cui parlavo prima
io ho detto alcune cagate nei video mia
madre che si ubriaca l'amico interista
sbarazzino che sono tutte cose finte
ovviamente nessuno mi ha detto niente su
queste cose qua ed è proprio qui che mi
è sorto il dubbio ma la gente li
guarderà tutti sti cavolo di video e al
loro fatto l'ennesimo test
nel video di natale poco prima di natale
ho detto la più grande cazzata che gli
sarebbe mai potuta venire in mente mi
dispiace ma io non farò il video al
natale non lo faccio perché purtroppo è
successa una cosa un po triste
mia zia è morta mia zia è morta è andata
in cielo niente era venuta a portare i
regali mi sembra e purtroppo non sia una
mi chiamo al terzo piano e non c'è un
ascensore e e non so è scivolata e ha
sbattuto la testa è andata in ospedale
ma non non sono riusciti a salvarla e
purtroppo è morta quindi io ci sarà la
veglia funebre e poi andiamo a fare il
cenone di natale quindi a natale non ci
sarà nessun video
sì e mi sono arrivati alcuni commenti
che però mi ha fatto capire che il vino
mi sa che non l'hanno visto quindi per
il quarto video ci vuole qualcosa di
forte bisogna parlare di qualcun altro
e siccome non vogliamo creare grandi
casini ho detto facciamo che parlo bene
di qualcuno e di chi vuoi parlare se
vuoi fà le visualizzazioni veloci se non
del povero lorenzo che ciccia fuori ogni
3x2 in ogni singolo in ogni 5 la
discussione su youtube
tutti ormai fanno i videogiochi ma fa vj
stato il primissimo che ha fatto
videogiochi e per questo mi piace perché
è molto simpatico e mi fa vivere sempre
e io vorrei diventare come lui
lorenzo per bona bier fest e cosa
succede o suo 200 visualizzazioni un
sacco di mi piace e non mi piace strano
funziona vabbè sarà che ho detto anche
lì una marea di cazzate
sì magari è stato anche un po per quello
per erano teste per prendere visuale
sono arrivate
e siccome erano passate tre settimane si
arriva a gennaio dove decidono di che
l'esperimento può finire qui perché ho
passato di tutto collaborazioni e dissi
iscritti this iscritti spam
ho fatto tutto quello che dovevo fare
quindi smetto di fare video perché mio
papà non vuole mio papà ha scoperto che
ho carico i video su youtube
mi ha detto che se non smetto di mettere
i video mini se queste al computer e
sempre per vedere se la gente avrebbe
visto tutto il video no ho lasciato una
piccola chicca una piccola sorpresa nel
finale
e allora ho detto che ho dovuto
utilizzare il computer e allora ho
finito cavo non caricare il video sul
canale principale dai forza ma basta
bastato detto esci forza forza forza non
allora va male lei subito subito e
qualcuno se n'è accorto infatti mi stavo
divertendo grandissimo legge come ti
dico mamma ma quello yotobi anche se un
paio di persone aveva qualche dubbio
anche io avevo pensato che era aiutò b
se no perché dice che deve caricare un
video sul canale principale le opzioni
sono 21 o il figlio di yotobi ovvio due
opere sola voce di youtube da uno dei
suoi video insomma col culo il finale il
video lo ha visto con un po di
confusione ma lo ha visto è qui si
conclude il viaggio di xx dark angel
kraft xx è però cosa ho capito da questa
storia qua che effettivamente
tralasciando il fatto che i miei video
fossero abbastanza merdosi fare
iscrizioni facili o fare visual facili
non
non esiste non c'è un modo a meno che
non passi tanto tanto tanto tempo farlo
come hanno fatto quasi tutti oppure
semplicemente ti fai dare una mano da
qualcuno e non ci vedo nulla di male e
io ho passato anni a sponsorizzare
canali ai tempi e adesso faccio più che
altro lascio qualche commento e
sponsorizzo in live molto spesso un
canale quasi ogni settimana almeno uno
lo sponsorizza ma c'è ancora molta gente
che sponsorizza i canali alla fine dei
loro video più che altro si fa quel che
si può perché ci sono problemi nel sei
big sponsorizzano canale perché parte
poi il treno del ma perché a lui ci
andremo poi io voglio essere il prossimo
è ma se fai le cose ordinate poi riesce
a farle no se uno fa le cose ordinate
diventa la caritas dovesse entry
lei è qui per farsi sponsorizza il
canale si prenda il numero detto questo
da questa esperienza ho capito che un
commento in più un commento in meno fa
la differenza e sicuramente nel futuro
lo terrò a mente e tra l'altro come
potete vedere ho voluto fare questo vito
in taglio documentaristico che a quanto
pare si fa sempre guardando
un'immaginaria persona tipo trequarti
non guardando la telecamera ma guardando
così perché fa bello e figo perché fa
documentario sulla seconda guerra
mondiale cosa farò dei commenti
probabilmente li toglierò perché non mi
sembra caso non mi sembra rispettoso nei
confronti di che ha commentato di fido e
dei video alla fine fasulli però il
canale lotterò con i commenti
disabilitati così potete vedere anzi
ascoltare tutte le cagate e ringrazio
tutti quelli che involontariamente hanno
contribuito a questo progetto che hanno
commentato che hanno visto che hanno
anche forse condiviso non ha idea se
sono riusciti anche a condividerlo
veramente grazie mille perché senza di
voi questo video non sarebbe mai potuto
citare fuori
[Musica]